ich erzähle ich das labor in vietnam
mehr oder weniger so wie sie sich das
vorgestellt haben
naja eigentlich nötig haben mir anders
vorgestellt
viel einfacher bequemer ist es ist alles
um mühsamen zu aufwändig und kompliziert
was wenn wir und unsere heimat einander
fremd geworden sind davon handelt dieser
film
[Musik]
warum wenn die liebe binden wir bilden
ja gut sondern ist nach 40 jahren in der
schweiz zurück in seinem heimatland
vietnam nach so vielen jahren in der
fremde hatte er gehofft endlich nach
hause zu kommen
[Musik]
die hat sie zeitdruck dass sido richtig
da zurück nein ich kann mich ja ihr
kollege minute die usa haben das macht -
wie so ein schräger vogel und wir jetzt
wollen der gewohnte rolle
respekt vor der natur einfach alles nur
herunterfahren
der wind kommt ist alles drin
er habe gehofft hier ruhe glück und
zufriedenheit zu finden sagt hahn
[Musik]
es sei sozusagen auf der suche nach
seiner mitte gewesen
die wurde ja von anfang an handgelenken
auf einem baustopp nicht wie sport und
sieht er mich das machen können die
solitaire lang ein buch und die
bewegungen wieder als war die video
absätze langsam und dass das ist nicht
möglich sie auf einen baustopp als im
radsport gang aber am linken bein nicht
so und hat mir sehr viel gruppen bringt
wirklich richtig dass user mit dem dass
uns das geht in östlicher hat ja mental
nur ja nur unzufrieden aber auch der
spaziergang mit dem hund
das gibt mir das bringen wir uhr in
sachen dank verarbeiter und
[Musik]
problemlösungen viel problems lösen
technischer probleme schon lösen
konstruktion zu problemen eigentliche
problem gegangen mit der musik das
problem und sucht die fehler
[Musik]
der anfang seiner entfremdung von der
heimat liegt im jahre 1968 toren war
damals elf jahre alt und in vietnam
herrschte krieg die usa versuchten
südvietnam mit nato-bomben zum sieg über
den kommunistischen norden zu verhelfen
eines unter tausenden von zivilen opfern
dieser nato-bomben hieß sondern in einem
spital nahe der stadt begegnete der
schwer verletzte junge einem schweizer
kaiser dem gründer von terre des hommes
kaiser brachte toren und sieben weitere
kinder in die schweiz sorgte für die
medizinische versorgung für eine
pflegefamilie und für bildung
[Musik]
wie ganz normal aufgenommen oder ganz
normal akzeptiert wurde
mir haben wir ganz nah miteinander
spielt fußball großmacht und übliche
üblichen urlaub doch wie immer aber
bringt sie dass sie dunkel sind von der
route und verbrannten eine idee die sich
super gurka mit der volksschule ja der
krieg hatte allerdings nicht nur dorns
körper fixiert sondern auch seine seele
lang lang keine albträume heute noch und
immer mit trecker und immer die gleiche
maschine die kanone und der helikopter
und motorflugzeuge dass das nehmen die
albträume sind
das ist laut lage die dann mit anfang
zwanzig sie ihr heiraten und mit ihre
drei kinder groß ziehen sollte
und wenn ich sie sich eine kleine aber
langsam mit allen zum abflug der glaubt
räume zu klären
ja das leben und nicht wie ihr die ich
da um ihn alpträume sind weg
[Musik]
für sich sido an war klar dass sie mit
ging als sich ihr mann mit 50 seine
pensionskasse auszahlen ließ und nach
vietnam zurückkehrte was hat sie sich
verliebt
die fil filipov der wahl und deshalb da
nur ein
[Musik]
seit acht jahren lebt sich sido a
geboren in meilen am zürichsee nun schon
in der dritten welt und ehrlich sind und
angriffe in buchloe haben das gut
am anfang bin ich noch ein paar wochen
aus dass künstler die fitness kann dass
ich mich gerne kommen - plan der
tennissport zu ende
das heißt widersprach
dass eine frau die offenbar bereit ist
einen hohen preis zu zahlen damit ihr
mann versuchen kann endlich anzukommen
die wälder und ist
ja hat er sich so depp ich mit nur mäßig
gefasst
die verstorbene verstorbene als bild wo
der körper gruppen alter und wird für
sie bei der du ahnst vater starb als er
drei war seine mutter als er elf war an
den folgen derselben napalm bombe die
ihm schwer verletzte ja da ich jede
wette sie immer wo die bombe aber
kilometer schlafzimmer ist das etwas
komisches gefühl an dem ort schlafen wo
sich so schwer verletzt worden sind
naja das ist das einzige ort wo man
immer findet sich an vernimmt mit das
haus ich auch tektonisch so blöd baut
also viel kann man nicht verändern wenn
man von anderen zusammen wenn man die
wand durchbrechen würdigkeit was ich
nicht kann und das war mir auch nicht
und dass ich die einzige logische
vernünftige lösung aber es mit drei
motionen verbunden dass immer der ort
die negative sind ja haben
schwer verletzt schleppte sich der
damals elfjährige zu seiner tante thane
sie versorgt ist eine brand- und
notdürftig und trug ihn eigenhändig ins
mehr als zehn kilometer entfernte spital
an so dass nur wenige der 16 jährige nur
aus erzählungen
es ist auch so lange ich vorgestern
vortragen wie das ist ja bis negativ das
ist links und was man sie kollegen unter
materialien und das ist ja auch erklären
warum das wecke große für ihre tochter
das ist eine neuerung
ja ja ja das ist immer mehr retten der
english sie das ist ein erlebnis das hat
immer groß weiß jetzt wo du mir da sind
wenn man probiere ich das aber wieder
zurückzog und bis zu wort ich mir kein
und mit sind jene zu wort locker wie
machen
ich will mich ja abschnitte aber hier
besteht das garten sondern hat trotz
allem das gefühl im leben viel glück
gehabt zu haben
er habe viel bekommen findet der nun
will er etwas zurückgeben
vor allem wollte er auch sein wissen
weitergeben erworben in einer
gärtnerlehre in der schweiz
er wäre gerne eine art
entwicklungshelfer für seine landsleute
geworden
eine sozialistische gesellschaft aber
auch die meta bauer hat sich halten tut
einfach nehmen und das lied zu schreiben
wenn sie es besser wissen wenn sie
besser ein wenig blut und so besser
jetzt haben die entwickler wenn sie
nicht weiß was ich meine
ich habe kein bedürfnis zugleich ja
wieso doch nur das hat jeder mensch hat
doch das bedürfnis sich zu entwickeln
als in la paz umstands verbessere legen
für sein wissen interessiert sich hier
niemand
umso größer ist das interesse freilich
an seinem geld und uns auch spenden sich
einen freundeskreis aufzubauen gestaltet
sich schwierig auch wenn die touren sind
zwischen passabel vietnamesisch gelernt
haben über small talk kommen sie kaum
hinaus zur sozialen isolation gesellt
sich die tatsache dass strom und
fließend wasser hier glücksache sind die
doors versuchen autos aus chance sich zu
sehen ist optimismus
also muss ich muss ich sagen so gut
unterstützen
wo also dass das für mich ja ich muss
mich aber managua zur rede gestellt
aber für mich ist für mich ja wohl
stimmt alles
[Musik]
die doors versuchen mir zu arbeiten um
weniger nachzudenken noch nicht
kontrollieren
nein
dass sich der winkel der mitgliedschaft
naja so gut wird aber ich glaube dass
ich natürlich in der fabrik es ist genau
das außerdem rutschte sie bitte mit
intelligent java
da ist noch offen und das ist auch ganz
schwieriger prozess
das wollen wir durchmachen müssen auch
durch darf sie und bereit sie zu
restaurieren
es ist nicht so einfach
unter uns gesagt auch bei den toren ist
nicht mehr alles wie einst die motoren
wollte diesem schwierigen prozess schon
wiederholt eine ende setzen
wir mieten und so dargestellt
mango frau umfragen oder zum also drei
mal einig sei
ja wenn sie gut also wenn sie geordnet
was blieb mir anderes übrig denn dann
muss ich das heiligen mir ein mikro ja
oder oder anlage wie bitte machen aber
arbeiten klinger gesicht verleiht wieder
sondern sind kann man das gar nicht das
besorgen das kann man so viel viel
saison großer garten
[Musik]
conny und wahren ansturm nicht nur zum
teil und du und ich
und natürlich die videos stört das
mittelalter nein das ist doch nicht mit
leid dass ich irgendwie vernunft und
ewigi liebi oder außer kontrolle ließen
und wie geht es ihren kindern und enkeln
die sie zurückgelassen haben
mehr dazu am nächsten sonntag
[Musik]
er bittet für sich
die täter verbrannten
hier und sie waren
[Musik]
jetzt nennen